[Musique]
à l'hôpital saint camille de
bry-sur-marne l'espoir sont
le remettre un petit pas après des
chiffres qui avait explosé ces trois
dernières semaines les soignants observe
une légère décrue des entrées retour des
joueurs franchement j'en sais rien parce
que je ne crois en rien de ce que dit
gouvernement pour une bonne raison c'est
que tout ce qui a été dit par le passé
général été démentie une à deux semaines
après à la lecture du verdict à
l'intérieur la confusion et des cris et
une trentaine de policiers et gendarmes
à coup une bagarre générale a éclaté
certains accusés qui pourtant venait
d'être acquitté ont tenté d'en agresser
un autre dans une scène d'une violence
que je n'ai jamais vu en 25 ans dans une
cour d'assises le 8 octobre 2016 des
jeunes cagoulés s'attaque à deux
voitures de police
brisant les vitres et jetant des
cocktails molotov à l'intérieur la cour
d'assises vient de condamner cinq
accusés pour tentative de meurtre sur
des policiers
elle prononce aussi 8 acquittement
s'était accrue qui ont été condamnés
sont battus avec ceux qui ont été acquis
de l'air de dire moi j'ai pris pour toi
c'est ça que ça veut dire chez eux ça
sur la justice ça vous inspire quoi
pour la police à metz pire surtout drame
désespoir autant d'acquittement est ce
un pari tué parce qu'on vous pouvez en
fait tenté de tuer un policier vous
prenez ce en quoi vous êtes acquitté
servier sait pas quand on va plus
prendre une décision comme ça je sais
qu'on ne doit pas normalement critiquer
là personnellement je le fais parce que
je trouve que c'est vraiment un naufrage
total de la justice
cette un message terrible on donne aux
mineurs délinquants
ce qui est important ce n'est pas tant
la sévérité de la peine c'est sa
certitude en france ne vont pas à cette
peine de deux places de prison nous
avons une justice qui est débordée
il n'y a pas suffisamment de deux
greffiers et donc la justice a du mal
parce qu'elle est lente c'est un
déjeuner de travail pour deux personnes
ça ne se passe pas au restaurant qui est
fermé mais dans un salon oui bien sûr
alors ça c'est interdire vous le saviez
pas pardon c'est interdit d'aller
déjeuner dans un salon privé d'un hôtel
de luxe ou pas en l'occurrence là c'est
un palace mais c'est interdit d'aller
déjeuner compris dans un salon avec une
personne personne sache je l'ignoré ce
n'est pas parce que quelqu'un
éventuellement transgressent la loi ou
ce conduit
que ça donne le droit soit même de se
conduire comme une merde je veux dire
par les données l'analyse de médiapart
mais oui mais ouais se conduit comme une
merde je veux dire humainement
humainement on n'a pas le droit de
dénoncer à ne pas être humain vous
comprenez que respecter la loi c'est
important surtout en période où tout le
monde se restreint des je ne fais que ça
après un début de printemps doux
plusieurs vagues de gel ont détruit les
cultures émergentes
les expertises sont en cours mais un
chercheur a estimé les dégâts dans les
zones en bleu foncé arboriculteurs et
vigneron aurait perdu 70 à 100 % de
leurs récoltes
je suis venu annoncer donc un effort
tout à fait significatif de l'état à
hauteur d'un milliard d'euros car la
situation le justifie là il a réagi très
vite avec des moyens conséquents et avec
des outils qui ont été opérationnels qui
sont à peu près les mêmes que dans le
cadre de la crise du coc vide et dans
les cas de lait crise à l'école
précédente donc il ya une capacité de
réaction est incontestable je vous
propose de prendre un petit temps qu'on
peut appeler comme vous le souhaitez
mais tant de centrage comprenait un
temps de méditation collectif dans le
cortège funèbre ses quatre enfants
charles and andrew edwards suivi par les
princes william et harry
le but apaisé toutes tensions et éviter
des débats parfois houleux
j'inspire j'expire elle entre seul dans
la chapelle
il est 16 heures des coups de canon
retentissent